thanks and welcome everybody so we have
uh quite an impressive panel here today
and we'll be discussing different kind
of career trajectories so when you're
thinking about your career whether your
mid-career end of your career hopefully
not end end but senior or if you're just
starting out kind of how do you make the
choices and we have varied experience
here to kind of guide us
what advice can we garner from this
group of experts on the choices that
they've made
and so i would i would talk a little bit
about the experience uh i will go from
marielle towards me
so marielle is a doctor in applied
cognitive science
her thesis kind of showed collaborative
learning and the cool intersections with
graph visualization
she's worked in data science and
analytics and has done some freelancing
so those are the things that we'll talk
about today emily is head of data at
thoughtworks
she
has a non-masters in mathematics that
she will discuss a bit later and she's
been a consultant in numerous
geographies for quite some time and can
bring a lot of expertise on that and now
how to lead a team of consultants
seer is a founder and entrepreneur
c blank blank at many companies
part-time giving his expertise in
finance and growth so i think can be our
resident entrepreneurial expert for
those questions and also of course
managing director at konigsfeg which
offers consulting services and
freelancing services for numerous
companies across germany and i think
also europa wide
and
cat caterina has been a data scientist
consultant also software developer
also phd in computer science
as well as worked at
german enterprises before that so i
think and speak quite openly about those
transitions
mateo is also a freelancer and
consultant for
five plus years now phd in physics
theoretical or mechanical
solid state theoretical
excellent
and also a big part of the organizer
community here in berlin so i think
that's an interesting perspective so
my first question for those of you that
have touched on academia
what was the transition
from academia like to industry and
specifically
i want you to try to remember actually
how it was then not just the
survivorship bias that we all bring but
how it was then and how did you make
that transition so matteo maybe you can
start
yeah so
[Music]
what in the world maybe was daunting
really because of several reasons but i
think mainly when you're in academia
you're really in a bubble
so you don't think you can do anything
else
and so i think the heart one of the
hardest things was really to understand
what my
what
my skills how i could reuse my skills
outside of academia and what were the
opportunities that i could you know
that i could try
so
yeah
um
that would say is kind of the hardest
thing
it's a frame of mind that that you kind
of have uh
when you're in academia and when you
realize you don't really want to be
there anymore
so
yeah at least in my experience it really
depends because other people have other
you know other reasons not to pursue
academia um but for me it was really
like okay i don't it doesn't work for me
anymore
what do i do now you know i worked so so
hard to get here it felt like i you know
that was my track and now
i realize it's not anymore
so
yeah
and
personally i think in reality
there's always an opportunity for
you know for changing career it's just
that
if you're too much into your bubble then
you you don't think that's the case but
um
yeah
i think that's that's kind of the key
thing
for me
katarina yeah actually i want to
directly pick up on something mateo just
said about being in a bubble so i
and feeling like you can't do anything
else so i
finished my phd in computer science in
2013 and then was looking for data
science jobs in 2014 and i had this big
worry that i think many of you who are
kind of struggling with this decision
have is like if i go for it postdoc will
i be even more pigeonholed into academia
like is this the last chance
that i have of switching over to
industry um so i was quite conflicted of
how which which choice to make here in
the end i did go with with
industry because that fear was just too
big too big in a way
in the end for me at least the process
was very smoothly and i think i had
a number of advantages there number one
my
background in computer science and phd
that was somewhat related to to machine
learning
i think made it easier from for
employers to believe that i could be
working as a data scientist so i didn't
have to do as much convincing
and
um of course it was also a different
time so this whole
there's a data scientist the data
analyst a data engineer we didn't really
have that in 2014 you had more of a kind
of you did all of the stuff which
personally suits me suits me quite well
i like doing all of this stuff but you
don't
have this additional analysis paralysis
of well okay i want to go into data but
which of the things am i actually in
where where can i make my my
contribution so i in the end i did apply
at four jobs for most of them i got an
interview and for one one of the
companies i then picked and so i said
quite smoothly in the end and maybe i
could have done a postdoc and then went
into industry and it would have been
completely fine
yeah so um so unlike unlike cat um my
phd was not in a traditional stem field
so that made it a lot more challenging
for me um so my bachelor's degree was on
psychology
and learning so my that's my bachelor's
and master's so um i guess a lot of
people in tech don't really know what
like psychology as a discipline is about
um and so they like when i applied for
jobs like a lot of employers and hiring
managers didn't know why a psychology
person would be applying as a data
scientist um so that made it really
difficult for me to get my foot in the
door um
and yeah i think a really big challenge
for me was to convince them
like to convince them why like they
should even consider me um
so what i did um because i finished my
phd in 2018 and i moved to berlin i was
living in another city in germany i
moved to berlin because this is where
all the startups are i guess
and because my
phd was on psychology and education
i applied for an
edtech company
that was doing data science courses um
and i think like data science and python
courses so um that was in a way my foot
in the door even if it wasn't like a
perfect fit um it wasn't that difficult
for me to sell my skill set to them
because like i already have i guess i
guess the background in at least the
industry that they are in even if i'm
not technically a data scientist um but
i think so
so that was one i think challenge
convincing other people that i matter in
that sense and second is to like not
is to not i guess devalue what i just
went through i mean it is three years of
like you know academic study which may
or may not be valuable to industry but
it's definitely valuable to me and it
counts as work experience
and
it's not something that a lot of people
can do not a lot of people can have the
stamina to work on one thing for three
years
and now that i'm working in industry and
as a data engineer like i
no i'll never get that time back again
i'll never work on just one thing for
three years and be the master of that
one thing so yeah that's been my
experience
cool
emily you decided not to
pursue a
advanced degree however i do know that
you did quite a bit of advanced degree
studying can you talk about why you made
that decision sure um
the decision was actually kind of made
for me when i did my undergrad
my goal was to actually do a phd and
the last year of my undergrad i got
really really sick and i had to take
almost four years off before i could
finish my degree i had one semester left
and in that four year period of time i
was
working sort of odd jobs while i was um
getting healthy and
lived for a
pretty long time on like a minimum wage
salary and at the end of it when i went
back and i got my degree i was thinking
do i really want to go to grad school
and and be broke for like another five
years
and the answer was no
and
so i went and i left and i found a
company
in the private sector doing research
because what i really loved doing was
research i i really wanted to be
pushing the envelope doing something new
doing something that nobody has done
before and so i was lucky enough to find
a company that could take me in um
to do research but
i kind of
do
every once in a while i kind of have
like a little bit of a regret that like
i never did get to go back and do my phd
um
but do i like if i were to think back on
it do i regret it no like i made the
decision because
i i knew that i wanted a different kind
of lifestyle after
you know four years that's like a good
chunk of a phd
so it's like i can't i just can't do it
for another another five
yeah
and sierra i know that you have a few
phds at codexfed can you describe a
little bit what that is like yeah sure
um so
basically what we heard here was um
this huge variety of um
i think what you just said was very
impressive i did not make the choice but
the choice was more or less made for me
um so it is about like uh individual
situation individual um
passion individual
uh financial background maybe whether
you can pursue this or not and whether
you want to be a researcher so
i think it is not about just
normally after the researching period i
need to go into industry but it is maybe
first of all you have this kind of idea
to be within academia and then step by
step it
it decreases from the
whatever reason ability or
ambitiousness
so what we do have at queen expect we
have a lot of
interaction with people whether they
work with us directly or as freelancer
in any way or form because we will talk
about this and particularly i i asked
lucas he's one of our fellows he's today
with us here um i asked him whether i
can share him his
story and he said yes and so very openly
so he is a phd candidate
and um
we talked that he would like to stay
within this
phd system and try to get it done for
several reasons individual motivation
what you just said that it is like a
very very good thing to focus on one
topic and master it for a couple of
years but still from the financial
perspective it is very intriguing to be
in the freelance situation and do some
projects so we find a situation or in a
system where it is like um three to four
days focused on the phd two to three
days uh focusing on the
additional project and we've found
together a long term project where we
collaborate and it is working and it is
very this is important very open and we
collab communicated this also to the
research institute so it's not this kind
of
don't ask don't tell
yes i work on my phd but i did some
other work with very very open note this
is the period where i focus here and
this is the period where i focus there
and
why do i share the story because i think
each situation is individually and just
try to find the tribe to find a good
situation it's not always possible it's
not always
[Music]
obvious but i think if you look
intense enough you will find good
solutions where you
get these things under one umbrella
well i think it almost loops back around
to several things i heard which is
getting out of an academic only bubble
so you feel like you have some industry
experience
getting some of the skills on your
resume that makes it a little easier to
say
hey you did graph visualization and
collaborative learning this is like a
ton of data science but if people don't
see this and that technology sometimes
they think oh this person can't do these
things
yeah
great cool so now we're kind of
transitioning to talk about freelancing
and employment so
i know several of you have done
freelancing now for a long time i know
some of you had a brief stints as
freelancers
so my question is how do you even
compare the two so what's really the
difference between bringing being a
freelancer and you know self-employed
and being an employee
and what worked out best for you and why
and so katarina i will ask you to start
okay
um so after
i transitioned out of academia i was
first employed for three years
at a larger company and then decided to
to go freelance
and i think
for me well three years in the world
already in the water already right um
and free them in two kinds of ways
number one as mentioned earlier i love
working on all kinds of stuffs and i
think
you can get that in a company but you
have to work really hard for it but i
can just you know finish a client that
was maybe more on the computer vision
side and then work on another project
that is maybe more
straight up software engineering rather
than data science and i do like that i
do like kind of mixing it up like that
and the freedom of
picking how many hours i work
summer i shouldn't be doing full time
it's winter and it's locked on might as
well get to work
so kind of
being able
to
find the amount of work that fits my
situation right now
is probably something that is very hard
to do in a in a traditional employment
setting
how
like from our perspective if we interact
with uh
people who would like to collaborate
with us
i always ask um
what do you prefer so what kind of
person are you
because from the from the financial
perspective being a company it is pretty
easy math right you're all engineers or
most of you
and um so it's about the parametric so
if it's a dedicated
budget that it is possible to to pay for
certain work
then
it's all about the numbers regarding
whether it's uh self-employed or whether
it is um
this funny word in german right
so it is like
[Music]
you do the math and then you deduct like
the um social security aspects and
whatever so each situation is individual
from the budget perspective um there is
no much difference from a company
perspective whether you engage in a
freelance mode or an employed mode
because from my perspective in this area
and in this
economy and in this industry that we are
this
digital nomads that most of us are
we do not need to fear these kind of
under normal circumstances even in
crisis like corona could abide or
whatever in contrast to i don't know
working in
the gastronomy or in the production
phase or whatever so this gives us a lot
of freedom this gives you a lot of
freedom and then it's an individual
choice in most perspectives with the
respect that not every situation is the
same
and mateo i know that you have both kind
of worked independent and then also
sometimes
with organizations like similar to
konigsvig
what what has your experience been
yeah i
so i don't know if you compare that with
employment but
in terms of
so the difference between the two
well you could say you know you
you sacrifice a little bit of of pay
when you go through another organization
to find work but
most of the time i think the benefits
are
[Music]
are more than the negatives because
first of all you don't have to find a
client which is one of the hardest
things as a freelancer
and uh
and also if there are any issues with
the client
your shoulders are
much larger right so you're not all by
yourself
um
and
and everything becomes uh easier in the
sense that you know bureaucracy and
little annoyances there's somebody else
that can take care of that and you can
only you only have to focus on
on the work that you that you're
interested in basically
you know supposing that you're
interested in the project you're doing
um
yeah so
in general i i found working with with
the
consulting agency or or similar
organizations
uh quite uh yeah quite useful and quite
quite rewarding you know
marielle i know you had a brief stint
yeah as a freelancer do you want to talk
about it yeah sure um i think uh the
biggest difference between being
employed and being
a freelancer or a contractor is that
when you're a contractor you're expected
to be an expert at what you do
um so
i i like to joke at least based on like
what i've seen in companies that i've
worked for like when they're at
appointment a company is at the point
that they're going to hire an external
person
to do something they're kind of
desperate for that person's expertise to
get whatever it is they want to get done
done quickly and well
and
so when you're a freelancer my
impression is that you have to be an
expert at what you do but when you're
employed um of course you're hired to do
a job and you have to be good at that
job but there's also this expectation
of for the company to help that person
grow in their career so by offering them
like a you know a learning budget maybe
allow them to be experimental with you
know tools and certain skills that they
still have to pick up on the job so
learning on the job is in a way
acceptable when you're employed
and as a contractor maybe less so so so
in my experience like i um
that there was a time when i couldn't
find full-time work that i did some
freelance work um and that helped me not
only like um tied that like unemployment
unemployment stage over because then i
wasn't unemployed technically um but
that also allowed me to be exposed to
different kinds of projects um um also
increase my i guess my industry
experience um but ultimately it wasn't
um
it wasn't for me because of yeah
i just wasn't allowed to be experimental
it didn't feel right to be experimental
um when i'm being contracted to do a job
um
but i guess in a way i would recommend
that for for you know for people who um
recommend freelancing for people who
want to want exposures to exposure to
different kinds of projects and maybe
industries so especially when you work
in data then you'll be exposed to
different kinds of data sets and you
will learn how to deal with different
kinds of different kinds of data
but if you feel like because i don't
come from a stem background if you feel
like you have a lot of catching up to do
with the rest of your peers then i would
recommend being employed instead
so yeah but i i also still like to do
some occasional freelance side projects
yeah again for the exposure to different
kinds of fields and data sets so yeah
yeah that's interesting and i know i
don't know if you would like to share
katarina but i know you also kind of
like have
periods if i recall correctly where you
decide to explicitly do self-study and
not take on projects i don't know if you
can share that experience
yeah i mean there's a
lots of of
ideas are cheap but sometimes you
actually want to build them and so for
example this is something i did
i did last year in the comfort of just
having finished a a large freelancing
contract i just took a few months to
work
on my things without being constrained
by the technologies chosen by the client
and without yeah but this is a one
part learning thing and part
kind of feeling that you have
accomplished and you finished a side
project
which is really hard to do
when you are actually employed and have
to do work and then work on your side
project so i found it very
freeing that i could take the time to
just focus on that and to get it done
and then it feels really nice like yes i
did that
yeah
yeah i think this is a really
interesting question of how do we
develop and grow when we're supposed to
be experts all the time i think is a
question that
often comes up
at my new workplace which is
thoughtworks
and so
i guess one of the questions i have
emily for you is
years of consulting variety of
consultancies
what is kind of where are the lines
between what you do as a freelancer what
you do as an employee and then what you
do as the consultant when you're either
of those
yeah i think consulting is an
interesting place because it sort of
fits in between you have
on one hand all of the drawbacks of
having to find the clients but also
not having the freedom to do whatever
you want because you're essentially on a
contract basis
at the same time you do have a much
broader
basis on which to stand especially when
you have a consulting company you have a
network of experts that are there with
you you have people who are able to
support you
and so i think that
it's
it's an interesting place to be in
because
people don't
usually bring in consultants just for
work they're bringing in consultants for
change
a freelancer might be brought in as a
subject matter expert but
most of what i see at our clients is
that freelancers are brought in to
augment their the workforce um i think
that when you're a consultant you're
usually there to do something different
and what makes that difficult is
um
there's a reason that the company hasn't
been doing things different there's
usually a resistance to change or a
fear of the uncertain or an
unwillingness to take risks and so as a
consultant you have to be
very confident
that what you are
telling your client is the right thing
to do which means that you there's a lot
of
work that you have to do in order to
know what you're talking about and then
also have the confidence that you can
teach other people what you're talking
about um so i think that it's
it's got a lot of positives in that um
it really stretches your abilities in in
multiple ways right you don't just have
to improve yourself but you have to
improve everyone around you
here how does this
yeah well um i just try to recall the
question and try to understand like the
difference and and
from the logic perspective because i
strongly agree that um
consultancy
depends or relates to
experience and some kind of
technical competencies when it comes to
subject matter experience but also this
whole
cultural aspect of communication skills
and convincing people and so on and so
on so this is definitely
a part of
consultancy but i'm not really sure
whether it is like this huge difference
whether you are
employed or whether you are
a freelancer because i think also if you
are employed within the company is
absolutely a realistic scenario that you
are an internal consultant or a
consultant to your customers or clients
so that's why i'm trying to to
understand like um where
the
our typological so
if
i would i would try to put it in that
way
you should always
uh in the best scenario try to get
better and better whatever you do and
try to master whether you're
self-employed freelancer or whether you
are employed within the company or some
kind of organization
step by step sooner or later hopefully
you
get into the situation where you can do
consultancy and hopefully at one day it
will be even good consultancy because
then the best situation
um
[Music]
and
i think
also if you're today a freelancer or
contractor for instance if if you being
a freelancer or contractor interacting
with us at kunixvik i think you really
should demand
not just being someone who's doing stuff
you should really demand
this kind of
learning experience support experience
being part of also internal community or
um
like not being this this contractor um
so this is like the
even from a business perspective even
the advice that i would give to you
interacting with us um have like a self
standard and and hold up for it and hold
us accountable because i think it is
really yesterday's
uh way of working that there is this
kind of hierarchy where you say yeah you
should just you have the this is the
contract and this is like the 10 days
and just deliver it and be finished i
think this is over um and if not
hopefully it will be over soon so for
with us we don't do these kind of
interactions and that's why yeah and and
that's the reason that that's maybe i
need to emphasize again why i come to
the point that it really doesn't matter
whether you're in this way or that way
because um it is then more a technical
aspect or a or a legal aspect
yeah it's kind of this bridge between
like the old school way of outsourcing
where you just said like here's exactly
what i want built and you just throw it
to somebody and kind of newer or more of
this era which is like strategic
advisory
how do you influence without necessarily
being internal go ahead
just one one thought because within
corona we understood this that even with
all our clients like the whole internal
company culture shifted so they finally
understood that definitely you can do
work on a remote basis and it is very
good and it is reliable and you can
trust the people you can trust the
internal people you can trust the
external people so it's not necessary
that everyone needs to be on site
and with the whole logic of everyone now
fighting and and
trying to get the talents on board
they're happy whether they're um
internally or externally they're happy
that they get good people anyway so
that's why i'm saying the position the
the the
how you say it like the um the situation
of
anyone being an expert is a very good
one it's like a seller's market and
that's why you can then also have a
specific
skill set that you can also demand from
your customer and or your consultancy
agency that you deal with and this is
what i would recommend to anyone just
hold everyone accountable around you
and if i if excuse me if i can just add
to that i think
one of the things that we see in the
software industry that we're starting to
come to the realization of is that um
you know we learned a long time ago that
building software isn't like building
bridges right you don't come up with a
spec and then you send it off and
somebody builds it and then they ship
you a thing and then you put it together
right that's that's not how software
works
that
also needs to extend to how we do the
hiring and how we do learning right you
have to understand that you can't just
contract out somebody to build you
some part of an api or something or to
do some sort of data analysis like
learning
on the job that that adaptability that
agile mindset is part of it and you do
have to bake that into everything that
you do and so
i think you know to to your point
one of the struggles that i see with
companies is when they're hiring either
freelancers or consultancies
is the expectation that it is just a
build me a widget
and
what we
one of the big challenges that we have
to face in this in any sort of contract
work environment is coaching
the client that actually learning on the
job is a feature and only through
learning on the job can you get to that
flexibility that you need in your
software product so it's actually
it's not just like that you should do it
because it's the right thing to do and
like
we want it but it's actually the thing
that you do to make a better
piece of software
and marielle how does this work
internally when you're an employee do
you feel like internally what has been
your experience with advising on these
types of decisions
without being an external consultant
um
so do you mean with like stakeholder
management yes um
i guess it's really
tough to i mean yeah i think it's yeah
really difficult to um
get
like that i guess business teams on
board with the decisions that you're
trying to make as um the person
responsible for the back end let's say
and this is where i find being a
psychologist really comes in handy
because i feel like
i don't know it's just like i feel like
i have been dealing with people from
like a meta level for a long time
um
and
that's i guess a really relevant
question for me actually lately because
um i just joined a new company um and
they hired me specifically for my
stakeholder management skills which i
which really is just communication
skills really so it's
not even like communicating as in saying
saying the right things but actually
just listening to the people that you
interact with and maybe try to find
their pain points and try to address
that so um
so i like for example like recently i
had to deal with with someone who
was tasked to migrate some sql queries
to a different tool and they didn't want
to do that and all i did really was just
to sit down and ask him why you know he
doesn't want to do that and he basically
because he's loaded with a bunch of
other stuff
that he still has to do with like with
external clients um and he knows that i
was being hired to actually do the
migration and so he was like why do i
have to do it if there's an expert here
already and i was like okay then why
don't i do 90 of your work and then you
can support me by giving feedback like
am i migrating the right queries does
this need to be refactored um and he was
like yeah cool and then i went back to
my manager
and he said um well you could share the
workload
um and i said well i think we shouldn't
give
[Music]
an important task to someone who doesn't
want to do it because they'll just do it
badly so
all of that to say i think um
yeah i think
maybe
talking again about transitioning from
academia or non-stem to to to tech like
i think you shouldn't
underestimate the
the
the value of quote unquote soft skills
because at the heart of it like it will
be the main blocker for you to get
anything done is if you don't see the
people behind the technology that you're
building
um and yeah i think there should be more
psychologists i think
[Laughter]
[Music]
thanks
um katarina what has it been like for
you like how much coaching do you do
versus
programming in your
consulting
um
all of the projects i've had so far are
the kinds of projects that you have
mentioned where kind of i'm being
embedded
in an existing team that needs a helping
hand and maybe needs some specific
expertise but actually mostly needs a
helping hand because it's hard to hire
data scientists
and
so
yeah my i don't think my work
is looking much different
than if i was employed my contracts are
usually like six months so it's ongoing
with with that same team
four four six months and um of course
then it's a very similar relationship as
if you are a senior person joining a
team of course there's some some
coaching and mentoring going on towards
the people already working there what i
did i did see a bit of this
not to build a widget and then give it
to us mentality but i have had some
clients for which i did work embedded in
a team but still kind of a little bit on
on my own thing and i backed them
to do a handover and there was just no
interest there like i didn't i didn't
get the feeling that whatever i had
built
mattered and was was going to be used in
the future and i found that really quite
quite puzzling it's such a waste of of
their six their money for the six months
in my six months that i'm doing all of
these all of these contributions and i'm
getting great feedback for them but then
there's kind of a lack of of integrating
that
with the rest of the company even so i
am kind of part of that
of that team so that has been
especially recently for me a bit of a
yeah kind of sad experience in in
freelancing um
yeah
and mateo
do you see a big difference between your
work and consulting work
um
no i don't think so uh i guess
maybe the scale is different because in
consulting you have longer projects
so there's probably a continuum
but i think
the way i approach my work in general
then you know depending what clients you
find as as cat
said but it's
the same way that was just described so
in terms of like
communicating and trying to find a
solution together
i don't think
being the expert are something and then
you know being the person that has to
solve everything
is uh
is the correct way of doing things
uh at least not for me i'm definitely
not that type of person i like to do
different things i would never be the
expert at a single thing i just can't
so
but yeah as as mariel said like
communication and soft skills that's
that's really the jam like
you can always learn uh
i
think technical skills uh in a
relatively easy manner
especially if you're from a from a
stem background
but soft skills
are statistically harder to
learn
it seems
and and then they are actually the main
blockers so
um
in that sense
yeah there's not a lot of difference
between financing and consulting
because the core is
communication in the end it's just a
different
scale
yeah
i think we're starting to see a theme
here which it really doesn't matter
where you sit in the organization inside
exa outside at a big consultancy outside
independently
if you have the way to influence the
stakeholders and you understand what
they're going for which means psychology
maybe hire more
then perhaps you can come to the same
conclusions right and make sure that
people feel like their work is valued
their contributions are valued
so i will have one final question before
we turn it to audience questions and
that is i'm a recent grad
i'm entrepreneurial and i'm also quite
interested in research
should i
pursue a phd
should i go into industry or should i
found my own startup
okay sierra i start with you
or entrepreneur in residence well um
yeah that's that's not a really fair
question because this is like
i don't know win win win lose lose so as
i have tried to mention each
situation is individual for me
personally it was
um
pretty clear and easy because i was
doing my masters and then directly
during my master's i already founded the
first company and having my
older sister as a role model
and she's she became a researcher she's
a researcher today she's in academia and
i understood
personally very soon that she had the
determination to really really focus on
this one thing and become like the world
champion in this one discipline and i
was not made for this so i'm a much
brighter
interest that's
my mastery was in geography and if you
do geography you know more or less
nothing from everything a little bit so
yeah this is like how it is and you
don't have like this really deep
professionalism so that's why to me in
my personal situation it was pretty easy
and that's why
in the continuously
biography of myself it's understandable
that i've
founded company after company and then
interacted in different projects but if
you
this was your question if you
are in the situation that you're really
determined and you really try to focus
and you really want to
achieve this
and our passion about this one topic and
you can
really
allow yourself to invest this
focused time and also have the stamina
to do this for a couple of years right
this
is like remarkable
and i think personally do it because
based on this
basement like founding a company it's
also possible to do this then later in
stage so you can see in more or less
every statistics that the most
successful companies are founded by
people around 40 and 50 and that's for a
reason because you have a certain
experience you have a certain network
you have a certain understanding of
maybe internationalization or
interacting with very very professional
people and folks around you
then
on the contrary the good thing is if you
found a company with age of your 20th um
you are a little bit
[Music]
as i was naive
and this is not always the baddest thing
because then you you
talk yourself into stuff like yeah i can
do this
although it's very clear that from the
objective aspect under no circumstances
you could do the so
that would be like my two cents to this
excellent oh yeah
um i guess the only answer that i can
give
is probably
yeah i think
yeah it's the reason why you should do a
phd which is to me just one which is
that if you really love a topic and you
want to do a deep dive into it for three
four five years
um think because like academia is its
own career path and so if you want to go
down that path then do a phd um and i
don't think i've ever i've heard a phd
like transition out of academia because
they fell out of love with their topic
so to speak it's usually because of
the environment not being the best or
for financial reasons or whatever but
it's really the like if you there is a
topic that you love and are interested
in so much that you want to stick with
that for a number of years and do it and
don't do it because in my opinion just
don't do a phd if you think it will you
know get you a job in industry unless
it's computer science um i think maybe
that's a different discussion but like i
don't think it will necessarily improve
your chances
of getting a job in industry i guess but
again i guess it depends whether it's a
stem phd or not um and
also i don't think it's a good idea to
do a phd if you don't know what else to
do because i really wanted to do my phd
and that wasn't fun so i can't imagine
doing a phd because it was the only
option like that is not going to be a
fun
fun next few years for you so i think
that's what i would say
sage advice okay so a resident phd in
computer science
okay so
i wasn't in love with my topic
and i kind of just did the phd because
it was there
saying said with the privilege of having
done the phd in a country where it's
properly funded in sweden where it's
properly funded and you have good
working conditions and and all of that
the topic was given to me by the project
that kind of employed me there and i saw
it through
um
it seemed like a good idea at the time
um
uh i agree so with what you said that i
mean don't do a phd if you think it
brings you forward in in your industry
career
um
what i did
take away
from it was very little to do i think
with the research i did but just this
kind of
five years it was
where i was studying that's kind of what
it's accounted for at the beginning of
your studies
um
and it's just such a long it seems like
an
unsurmountable
mountain and you're standing in front of
it and you're supposed to
kind of climb up to it and just see
the confidence that you can see a hard
problem
and you know just just you know take it
step by step by step
and you're going to get there
i think this is the my main thing i took
away from the phd and of course phd is
not the only place you can build these
skills for me it was
it was how how i built them and i think
how what helps me most now also with my
my freelancing yes i mean these projects
that come onto my desk yes they sound
again they sound unsurmountable but just
you know step by step by step
matteo what would your advice be
yeah so
i i think the short answer would be what
what sears said like
think about what you can do when
so the older you get the more pg seems
like not
an ideal
option or a harder thing to do
but it's funny because
i think i have a similar story to cat
in that you know
i studied physics i was deep into the
academic track i didn't
even think i didn't know what else to do
really
and at the same time i was extremely
lucky to find
incredible people
to work with
my master thesis and my phds is it was
in the same group
um
and uh and so i did it and it was pretty
amazing you know i traveled in so many
places for conferences
and
it was i think
you know and it's more the exception
than the rule this should be said you
know i'm extremely lucky
um
and but i feel like for me it was a
necessary time
uh for for growth for personal growth
uh because you know then i did my phd
and then i did my postdoc so it's like
seven extra years after university
and you would think like oh
a bit of a waste of time isn't it but um
[Music]
personally i just needed that time you
know maybe not four years of postdoc you
know we could debate around that but
but i think
in the end the answer is find good
people to work with
uh what you actually do
it's less relevant because if you go you
know you won't really want to work for a
company and you find
horrible people horrible culture
it's going to be bad and the same for
for a phd
phd is a little bit more specific you
know as a thing so
maybe
you know think twice
uh
but um yeah if you're interested in
research
try at least you know get good funding
you know that's the first thing
because
yeah you know otherwise it's not gonna
work but you'll see you i mean if you go
to a professor because that's what you
do you you look for people that can pay
you
and they say oh you know we have this
project we have this money and they
tell you up front
it's already a very good sign
if they never mention the money
uh you know maybe that's not a problem
for them it's going to be your problem
so
sure yeah
i actually have one point to add to
to my thoughts earlier
how has having stumbled into the phd was
actually the guy at the unemployment
office
who said to me well your grades are
pretty good why don't you do a phd i was
like okay
but never thought never crossed my mind
never before so
sometimes you just stumble into this
stuff
emily uh i'm curious do you ever regret
after those first four years either
founding a startup or pursuing advanced
degrees
i
regret not pursuing an advanced degree
because
i don't know where my limit is
and that if you know me is something
that um
affects me very deeply um so maybe one
day i will go back and do a phd
um i don't ever regret not creating a
company although i did actually create a
company when i was 18 and it was a
terrible like it's so much work
and it was not
like i don't know it was fun to do but
it had no chance
um i would say if you're if you're like
a grad like newly graduated or
graduating or new to your career and
you're trying to figure out what you
want to do i would say
take two years and go travel the world
and fall in love first
and then once you've done that then
figure out what is most important in
your life because
when you create your identity around
your work
you it comes at
the expense of a lot of other things and
you have to prioritize what that is so
if you want to
start a business if you want that
independence
and that becomes your priority and you
know that then then do it
because if you try to do it
when you're older it's i mean running a
business is a ton of work it's going to
take time away from your family it's
going to take time away from you caring
for your parents it's going to take time
away from a lot of things
if you
want to do a phd it's a lot it's not
impossible but it's harder to do when
you're older because you have to
you know you've worked you've made
income and then all of a sudden your
income falls off of a cliff
and you're probably also going to have a
much more difficult time competing with
the people who are coming straight out
of the university and also learning gets
harder as you get older
i think that's a psychology fact
and but if you want to do work and if
you want to make money then do that too
but it's it's just all of those paths
they have benefits and drawbacks and
i would say don't
feel obligated to choose one too early
because
the best thing that you can do for
yourself is to learn how to learn and
you can always change once you once you
know what your priorities
are that's good advice
incredibly useful advice i want to
transport myself back 20 years and get
all this advice then
don't we all yeah can we open it up to
any audience questions
don't know if we have a microphone
sorry
all right any audience questions
i like this one
all right thank you
um i have a question to this here sorry
for mispronouncing your name
um
so you talked about
being naive maybe in in the past
so if you were to give advice to your
younger self then what would it be
the advice that i would give to my
younger self is according to what emily
just said do it again
i'm
in that age
i'm just saying that looking now to that
what kind of uh
choices i did
imagine like i was 25 and the first
company was like an online ticketing
system it was a software system and
we thought about internationalization
and financial aspects and backbone and
blah blah and these things i never
thought about those back then we just
started we just started off we sold
tickets and then we understood like oh
okay there are some regulations and
stuff so nowadays i would really look
from a different perspective on it and
then
probably i would come to the to the
result that oh well it's not a real
business model because there are so many
competitors and there's this and that
and we are not expert enough here and so
this is what i mean that if you have
like 10 15 20 years of experience on
something it also could hinder yourself
or it could block yourself because then
you
really think things through and the
result is then ah you should not make it
and sometimes it's better if you just
in the nike way just do it right so
that's why
i would give to my 25 year old
uh
me the same advice
to my 30 40 old year old me
i would not give this advice
this is like the difference
all right one more audience question
hi my question is to emily you like
mentioned that you are still thinking of
getting back in academia to get the phd
what will be the discipline will it be
data science or will it be something
more social
philosophy that that's a great oh god
that's a that's a really difficult
question to ask me if you know if you
know me um
so
i
i think my first love is still
mathematics and i would love
i would love to go back and study
mathematics
and that's what i i started many years
after i graduated while i was
you know after i had gotten married and
bought a house i started working towards
a master's degree in mathematics and
maybe got halfway through and then
life happened and
all sorts of things and
ended up moving to germany and
here we are but
um
i think that
also in my
career i've done a lot in the space of
data journalism i've done a lot in the
space of
building medical devices and writing
software for regulated industries and so
i have a lot of passion in areas like
public health and policy and
i'm even like weirdly a
counter-terrorism specialist which is a
weird thing to say here
um so i've also thought about doing that
um
if or when i do it
um
it will be
for me and it will be because i want to
do it for me and not because i feel
obligated to do it for a career
that's good
okay
so now we're taking some questions from
online
okay
yeah i'm possibly doing something wrong
it does not look like there's online
audience questions at the moment
i think we have one more here
yes okay so going to the live audience
do you have an online question type it
quickly
anyone from the live audience
there's one over there
mattia are you typing an online question
[Laughter]
thank you for the discussion first of
all um i know a lot of people who prefer
to for instance start in big tech and
then move to freelance then have this
freedom or start in freelance and then
move to big companies with all that
experience
or maybe
found their own company
etc
i would not ask this question
to anyone in their 20s because they
would just start crying or something but
do you at this stage feel
comfortable with the style of the work
you have or do you still have a plan to
for instance migrate to something else
for instance find your own company or
expand your company or i don't know buy
out microsoft or whatever and if so is
there anything you do
in your workload that implements that
future a
i'll jump in with something so
i started
my career doing research for a company
that was
it was sort of like consulting it was
government contract research um so
somewhere in between consulting and
academia
and
after doing that job for
almost a decade i went to a product
company where i worked at and i worked
there for two years
and i liked the people i worked with and
i liked what we were doing
but
i really didn't like how
little influence i had over decisions
and so when i had the chance to get back
in the consulting i took it because
for me it was super frustrating just
being somebody who
would do good work but not be listened
to
and so i've kind of gone through that
and i think that i will always be
in a space where i will be
i will have
a strong degree of control over what i
do
um
but i you know i kind of did do that i
went through that change for myself so
for me like that's that independence is
part of my own personal value system
was there i think this the follow-up
question was was there something that
you did while you're at the old position
to kind of prep for that did you save
time or um
i think
yes so
one of the things like working in
research is
there's a much different standard of
quality and craftsmanship
which is a charitable way of saying i
wrote a lot of really bad code
um
and
learning how to be a proper software
engineer and developing that skill set
was something that i had to do
to go into that space and i'm i'm
grateful that i did that
um so it was definitely like there were
mindset shifts that i had to make to
prepare for that
so there's one question from online hold
on i think we have something yeah i i
just wanted to add
something i mean it's uh
one of the downsides of freelance for me
and that could urge me at some point
to go back to being employed is no i
always leave i start a job and i know
i'm going to leave there's
this is not
there's no way that i'm going to build a
community
i'm kind of part of the team but i know
it's transitionary i don't need to get
involved and also the annoying political
aspects of it but also i'm kind of
i'm really not
part of them the way that they are and
it's something i do miss from from from
being employed of having this team
around you if you if you happen to have
a have a nice even have a nice team and
nothing nothing i prepare for right now
but again it could be what makes me
switch back at some point
i would also like to add something um so
i personally would not change anything
right now i'm super
happy but i understand that um i was
really lucky
um to a certain point like jumping
directly out of university into this
entrepreneurship or entrepreneurial
career
and
understanding that
other folks around me who also started
had really really then due to not only
their individual mistakes or whatever
but just circumstances then for instance
issues in this german system for
instance to get a bank loan for
i don't know
getting your own apartment or whatever
so that's why i can understand that
there are these kind of advantages for
being like employed at a
bigger organization as one aspect
nevertheless uh the other aspect that
we
we tried to figure out so no matter
where you are and what you do
that
you should always try to find a
situation
where you have like the freedom of
doing what you do is beneficiary to you
but also in best case to society best
case to your people around you and even
if you are employed somewhere it is also
hard and you need to contribute and you
need to be dedicated with the
disadvantages to your family or to your
people around because if your company
does not perform even if you are
employed then your job is not secure so
that's why i always try to emphasize
that this kind of being employed or not
employed freelancing or not freelancing
from my personal perspective it's a if
it is a technicality because
your general
commitment should be always the same and
last thing
sorry but this is like the cfo
perspective so if you choose to be like
a self-employed or freelance
career and if you choose this then just
make sure that you have your tax in
order your savings in order prepare
yourself for being hopefully not sick or
have an accident or whatever do these
kind of private insurances so then at
the end it is a very comparable
situation whether you are
somewhere employed or not so this is
also like very important aspect that you
always
okay
thank you very much i have to apologize
to the online audience that i was unable
to take your questions it's entirely my
mistake
let's thank our panelists for today for
an interesting round
of
discussions and now we have a 20 minutes
break before we start
with
the lightning talks
thank you everyone for attending thanks
everyone extend thanks